this is a production of Cornell
University uh hello I'm Nina bassic I'm
professor emeritus from Cornell
University of the Urban Horticulture
Institute I'd like to share what we've
been working on with CU structural soil
for the last 20 odd years and I hope
it's uh useful for
you so the effect of soul vime is
something we've been working on for many
many years knowing that the larger the
soil viome and water and nutrients that
the trees can get the larger the trees
uh grow as you see here on Pennsylvania
Avenue in Washington DC Willow Oaks
quick as fellows uh in a large open area
of soil versus those in vaults suspended
from the sidewalk planted at the same
time you can see the effect of soil
volume on plant growth so we knew that
this was an issue especially under
pavement where you needed to compact the
soil to allow for load bearing of that
sidewalk and we decided to look into a
medium that could be compacted to meet
uh specifications engineer
specifications for load bearing as well
as have tree roots grow through
them so this is the issue when you L
laying pavement of any sort you need to
compact the subgrade the existing grade
so that the pavement will not subside or
crack or fall fail
and often we uh we would leave a space
for a tree but there's compacted soil
and rebar and reinforcement that
actually makes uh That Sidewalk very uh
loadbearing of course the see what you
see in the bottom of the slide is an
opening where the tree is going to go
and uh the hope is that the tree roots
can get out into that compacted soil
underneath the pavement uh often that is
not the
case we have a spef ification in the
United States called Proctor density
which is a moisture content that you can
compact the soil to a certain level that
gives you the greatest density um and uh
we say that we need to compact the soil
on under Pavements to 95 to% Proctor
density which is a moisture gradient and
um that is a quite a rigid uh standard
for
uh
specifications so we have compacted soil
that is brick-like often under paving uh
which has been compacted to Proctor
density or
more and you see loss of structure you
see it basically uh no permeability uh
very very small pores which don't allow
water to uh get through and also don't
allow roots to penetrate that
soil very often in parking lots we might
see uh a parking lot that's been
compacted to lay Asphalt in this case
and a space left over for trees but with
no remediation of that soil under the
around the uh curb so the tree roots
grow very shallowly and in this case uh
even with irrigation fell
over so the idea this is the kind of a
concept of what's the normal way of
planting trees so you have the
undisturbed subgrade and you have a
compacted base course of gravel maybe 4
to 8 Ines and then on top of that a
pavement service whether it can be
asphalt concrete um pavers whatever on
top of that and then into that profile
you create a space for the tree and
hoping that the tree will Roots will
actually grow into those um media but in
fact that doesn't really happen the fact
if the tree roots grow at all they get
into a area of weakness between the base
course and the pavement and uh are very
very
shallow here we see the tree being
placed into we call the coffin or the
the tree pit in New York
City and we've Lo looked uh often looked
at been able to look at where the roots
are under pavement here you see a tree
lawn a green strip with two fairly large
uh platinus um Acer platinoid and very
large trees and you see no way that
those trees could have those roots could
uh sustain that tree in that narrow
Green Lawn so we looked at where the
roots actually were using an air
excavation
tool and here you see the roots uh going
under the pavement just there a 4 inch
piece of concrete trees actually moving
through the soil right under the
pavement and going into somebody's front
yard or lawn and that's where the tree
is actually getting what it needs to do
uh needs to live water nutrients oxygen
so on so the roots are very very shallow
in under pavement very
often and we also see the effects of
volume on tree growth in Honey Locust in
Syracuse New York those on the right are
in tree pits those on the left are also
in tree pits but theyve able to the
roots are able to escape under that
concrete into a green space beyond it
and get what the water and nutrients
that they oxygen that they need so
providing a path for tree roots to get
into real soil is often a good way of
using structural soil as well as as
we'll
see so this often happens when tree when
pavement is uh moved too close to a tree
especially on the right the platinus
aerolia actually eating this sidewalk
and heing the side sidewalk which is a
major uh tripping Hazard and causes
several lawsuits as people trip and
fall we found that basically keeping
sidewalks
uh 2/3 to uh two meters uh uh away from
the side away from the base of the tree
actually prevents the sidewalk heaving
so two meters is a really nice distance
to allow for tree roots tree buttress
roots to grow without heing the sidewalk
so we came up with an idea that using
that we wanted to use the sidewalk area
between the curb and the building face
to plant trees putting in a soil mix
that could be compacted to meet the
engineers needs Proctor density and
still allow roots to grow through this
and to get the water and the oxygen uh
nutrients that they
need so why was seuse structural so
developed how does it work
basically it's a two-phase system there
the white angular pieces are Stone
particles gravel crushed gravel about
um um about 3 cm uh in diameter with no
fine particles so just the clean Crush
gravel and the soort you see the black
dots are the soil particles in between
those and so if you have clean crushed
gravel and you have a propor so that the
gravel is touching gravel is touching
gravel as the compactive effort goes
deeper the soil in the pores that black
dots will not be compacted because all
the loadbearing all the compactive
effort is being borne by those stones
and so it's an with the right proportion
of stone to soil and type of soil you
can get a good growing meding
medium so here's an in our area in
Western New York we use limestone is our
native Stone and it depends on what type
of stone you have you can use any type
of stone as long as it is U crushed uh
that one single size stone with a very
small measure of lower or higher
level and we use top soil LOM to a clay
LOM texture a pretty heavy uh texture
soil so that we can maximize the water
holding and nutrient holding capacity of
this since it is mostly stone with some
Part B basically 80% Stone to 20% soil
by weight so we want to maximize the
water and nutrient holding capacity of
that soil so we use a clay LOM to LOM
soil with about 20% clay in the
texture so here's a video showing of how
we made it
[Music]
I'm an urban Forester and a city for for
the city of via part of my job is to
keep trees thriving in a downtown
environment this environment is very
different from the natural setting in
which trees grow here we have asphalt we
have compacted subsoils we have concrete
and we have very little rooting volume
in which trees can
grow consequently trees suffer and
Decline and need to be replaced sooner
than they
should sidewalks are heaved and damaged
and need to be replaced accidents occur
due to these Heath sidewalks and cities
are subject to liability and
lawsuits Urban trees often have a very
foreshortened life a tree in the city
might live anywhere from 5 to 15 years
we in a rural situation A Park or Forest
they may live 50 to 100
years and therefore in urban situations
we're not getting the benefits for which
we plant trees the shade the noise
amiliar the dust particle
reduction The Dilemma we face is that
tree roots require a penetrable soil so
that they can grow for long distances
and get the water nutrients and oxygen
that they need on the other hand when we
have sidewalks surrounding trees
Engineers require the soil to be
compacted so that there's a loadbearing
surface to lay their concrete
on
well we've excavated this little leaf
linden tree here because it wasn't doing
well and we suspect that there may be a
root problem so we were uncovering some
of the roots to see what was going on
and here we can see something that's
very typical in tree pits with
sidewalkers surrounding them is that the
root gets to the end of the tree pit and
then cannot penetrate any further and
actually makes a right angle turn and
goes down where then it will grow a
short ways and then stop
again another example we see is that of
a major route here getting to the edge
of the tree pit and then following the
area of weakness the interface between
the concrete and the soil now this is
not satisfactory either because as the
roots grow under the sidewalks as they
get bigger they can actually damage the
sidewalks and we call sidewalk
[Music]
heaving
the challenge we face is to design a
soil mix which will meet the engineer
specifications for loadbearing of any
kind of pavement yet still allowed tree
roots to penetrate freely through their
soil to get the water nutrients and
oxygen that they
need pretty clean stuff the structural
soil material that we developed at
Cornell University is a fairly simple
blend of very angular Stone a soil and a
hydrogel the stone stone is a crushed
stone and the way that it forms a
lattice or a skeleton gives us all the
weight holding capabilities of the
mix into water and to keep the things
from separating apart once we start
mixing them we use a hydrogel which is
just a granular material that grabs 300
to 500 times its own weight in water
becomes quite sticky and that pretty
much binds everything together
stabilizes it and holds the soil and the
stone together when it's being mixed and
when it's being compa
acted use it this is kind of
wet the soil typically has quite a bit
of clay in it for nutrient holding
capability and water holding
capability we're using about 80% Stone
and 20% soil by weight in a very
minuscule amount of hydrogel typically
about 30 grams of hydrogel per 100
kilograms of
stone
[Music]
this is a field project that has been in
place for about three years now it's a
comparative study between what would be
a normal sidewalk profile in Upstate New
York minimal excavation compaction of
the subgrade and then 8 inches of a base
material before we lay the concrete pad
that's compared to this trench it's
running back and forth down here this is
a 24 inch profile of the stone soil
materials that we've been talking about
again this has been in for three years
now and we're getting ready to harvest
the whole thing because we have to get
the data from The Roots but you can see
above ground the difference is between a
standard sidewalk profile this is Acer
campestri or hedge maple a very
chlorotic very small increment as far as
yearly growth you compare this Maple to
a maple in the test
profile and you can see it's a much
darker Green Leaf we're getting a lot
more growth per year out of the shoots
it's a much faster establishment period
we think it's going to be something
sustainable we take a look at
lynen again short stunted growth here's
a here's a whole Year's worth of growth
very chlorotic leaves when you compare
it right next door to one that's growing
in the test profile we have much darker
leaves we've got much more vigorous
growth here's one year's growth
increment as compared to the less than
an inch on the one the standard profile
and it it's it's developing into a
reasonable shade
[Music]
tree the New York State Department of
Transportation and the City of via are
wrapping up a three-year 30 million
Highway rebuilding project as City
Forester I was very impressed with the
early Trials of Ral soil at Cornell
University it was planned to put about
10% of the over 500 new trees in the
material this involved an installation
of over 400 cubic yards of structural
soil and let me plant trees where
otherwise I wouldn't have been able to
get
them structural soil seems to lend
itself best to new construction we're
trying to end up with a large rooting
space we take it down about 18 in to 2
[Music]
feet we're spreading out the stone in a
layer so that we can mix this material
on the flat the structural St material
depends on having the stones touching
each other making the stone lattice to
Bear the load so that we can safely put
a pavement over the top of this
material we're going to sprinkle the
hydrogel over the top of it and the
hydrogel is what's going to stabilize
the system and hold the soil up in
between the
stones we've been spreading the hydrogel
onto the stone pad it looks a lot like
table sugar as you can see but even even
now just the moisture on my hand it
starts grabbing water very quickly it
can absorb 300 to 500 times its own
weight in
water once this hydroge gets wet it's
going to grab the water very quickly
almost explode into a water balloon and
hold the soil up inside the holes
between the stones it also gets a little
bit sticky and so we hope that the
material is gluing the soil to the
stones
we're spreading out the soil onto the
stones now the amount of soil is going
to range anywhere from about 15% to 22%
soil by weight of the total system and
that's going to be dictated by the shape
of the stone the size distribution of
the stone and some of the properties of
the soil
itself
we're mixing the materials now basically
just turning it in on itself coming in
from the sides and then taking a few
cuts out trying to get the material so
it's as uniform as possible couple
things to consider at this point number
one the hydrogel is grabbing water off
of the soil and expanding this is what
we want we're trying to mix as dry as
possible but if it's too dry the
material is going to start falling apart
so we do have a 3/4 inch hose on site
and we're going to wet the material down
if we find that it's still too dry and
it's falling
apart it'd be impossible for us with a
size Machinery that you see driving by
to mix 400 cubic yards all at once so
we're breaking it down to between 40 to
50 cubic yards and putting it onto the
main stock
[Music]
pile
for
we place the material into the trench
that's going to be used to plant the
trees in they're spreading the material
out can pack into 95% proactor density
that's normal for a sidewalk application
the nice thing is there's no specialized
compaction tests no specialized
compaction levels for this material
making it very cost effective for the
installing
[Music]
contract I believe that the structural
soil will work under any kind of
pavement we've tried under several
different types of wearing surfaces
pavers concrete
sidewalks asphalt parking
lots what's really exciting about
structural soil is that there's a large
volume of rooting space underneath the
pavement The Roots can penetrate there
and get the oxygen the nutrients the
water that they
need but often there's only a small
opening in the surface where we actually
plant the
[Music]
tree
city of vitha Department of Public Works
has mixed and installed Cornell
structural soil in several locations we
found it easy to mix relatively
inexpensive especially when compared to
the cost of replacing sidewalks
replacing trees and possible lawsuits
it's very cost
this material has allowed us to put
trees in places we never
would I believe that Coral structural
soil may help revolutionize urban
forestry in downtown
settings so uh you got that background
we did that about uh oh 15 years ago or
so and um we had a lot of information
since we've done that video and had
those trees planted so here I'm just
showing you again what the structural
soil looks like after it's
mixed and we've done several uh
experiments where we've done sidewalks
to Nowhere to look at where tree roots
were growing and here you can see the
root growth uh very strongly growing
through the structural soil Matrix or
skeleton or however or lattice way you
may think about it because the soil is
not compacted between the
stones um experiment we did uh while ago
showing the comparison of the tree roots
growing in normal sidewalk installations
versus cuu structural soil escalation um
installations and you can see from the
surface down to about 20 in um in then
standard profile you get get tree roots
growing only about barely 8 Ines which
corresponds with the base course the
gravel base course under the sidewalk
where in CU structural soil you get root
growth down to the entire depth of how
deep we put structural soil when in this
case was 24 inches and you get much more
root growth so that's a interesting
thing that we found with many more roots
in a panel versus those roots in the uh
standard structure a standard tree pit
profile so here we have Tri uh Street
trees growing to Nowhere sidewalks in
nowhere where we did various structural
soil versus standard soil profiles with
one clonal um culter bar of Norway
Maple and after three or four years of
these growth we then took it apart we
took up the concrete uh cut off the tree
we see the base course there that's
generally put under a
sidewalk and then we excavated with an
air excavation tool to uncover the root
system in one piece the entire root
system this is a structural soil root
system of that Norway Maple and you can
see the kind of Kink nature of it very
large root system after four
years we can have a look at this what
this looks
like
over a period of seven years we've been
observing terrific growth of these two
London plain trees growing in structural
soil CU structural soil in itha for as
long as we've been studying structural
soil we've been very interested in how
Roots grow through this new medium we
have an opportunity here to actually
excavate the entire root system so we
can transplant this tree safely we
wanted to do this because the trees were
planted under
wires this installation has about a 30in
depth of structural soil overlaid with a
geotextile and then a sand setting bed
where perious pavers are laid on
top we use an air excavation tool to
safely unearth the root
system here we can see the roots in a
quite a strong growth pattern angularly
moving around and through the structural
soil The Roots start at the surface but
very quickly move down in the profile
going down to at least 24 inches into
the tree pit
area we're seeing both massive roots
that tend to go down we might call those
Sinker
Roots as well as large but Roots near
the
surface after we Unearthed most of the
root system we took it out of the ground
and we actually transplanted it into a
park the tree here was about a 6 in
caliper tree it had been planted about 1
and a half inch is seven years earlier
but grown very very
well
some of those roots were so deep we
actually had to break them to get the
tree out of the
ground the root mass that we took out of
the ground was about 13 feet long and
about 8 feet wide so quite an extensive
root
system
we saw some massive Roots some really
strongly growing roots in the profile as
well as quite a bit of fine root
growth we saw some very interesting
features of how the roots move through
the
stone interestingly we saw some gravel
that was actually embedded in The Roots
which had actually grown around
encapsulating the
stone here again you can see some of the
gravel
wedged in between the roots Roots
growing right around
those and here's a really good example
of a stone being encapsulated actually
root growing around the stone and it was
wedged in there quite
tightly as roots grow through structural
soil they often get flattened and then
proceed to grow normally
again this doesn't have any negative
effect on root
function we saw deoration we saw
encapsulation we saw a lot of deep root
growth as well as roots that were up at
the top six inches below the
surface we have lots of evidence now
that Roots can grow very very well in
structural soil and the hope is that as
roots grow deeper there'd be less
potential for sidewalk heaving in the
future so um That Sidewalk to nowhere I
showed you earlier here's the uh example
of the tree in a typical tree pit again
compacted soil base course and then the
tree planting area so the tree root
system in this uh normal situation is
very different than what you saw on the
structural soil this is the typical
pancake like roots that you get when
Roots uh trees are grown in compacted
soil and that that root on the right
hand side that's going down is just
making a runner at the trench that we we
created there so typically you get these
pancake Roots which cause sidewalk
heaving and cause just less root growth
so the tree doesn't grow as
well here example is just the two conal
trees one in structural soil your on
your left and one in a typical uh treeit
instulation on your
right so the way we put them in the
ground as you can see in this uh
detailed cross-section is we go you know
24 Ines 60 cmers minimum depth and
preferably more like uh 90 or 100 cmet
or three feet down you have to have
enough depth to provide the soil volume
to meet the water and nutrient needs of
the tree and also um what we also came
to find is when you're where your
planting the tree where it doesn't need
to be compacted where there's open
ground we should put ordinary good soil
in that uh Sandy LOM or LOM soil to
maximize the water holding capacity one
of the weaknesses of SE structural soil
is it has a lower water holding capacity
and needs to be uh that area needs to be
maximized whether it's um in soil in the
tree planting opening or through
irrigation and planting of trees that
are drought
resistance here's one of our first uh
installations in 1997 where the street
was being narrowed and more sidewalk was
being put in so we added structural soil
there and over we put pervious pavement
uh block pavers these are ACA cestry
growing a couple of years
later uh this was in Brooklyn New York
where we had structural soil between
tree pits you can't see the structural
soil but it's between the tree pits and
then trees uh on your bottom left
there's the calorie pair andus
parolia um in tree pits but structural
soil between those that's three years
later and then 12 years later those same
trees in that uh growing
situation here's uh Frontier Elms almost
uh probably Folia Frontier and seosto
planted for after eight years and
they're growing very very
well Homestead Elms and 30-year-olds
zova is retrofitted with C structural
soil you can retrofit uh if you're
careful about working around tree roots
to add structural soil uh to an area in
fact there's um you can you can see the
the trunk size on these there's some
very large trunks which are zova which
are probably there for for 20 years and
the narrower trunks were the Elms which
grew very well and actually of matched
the size of the vovas after eight
years this is a plaza instead of using a
tree pit situation here's a plaza with
the calerie Pais Pirus cerina in Etha
New York after four
years we actually uh unbeknownst to us
the folks who were doing the Sydney
Olympic site decided to use structural
soil and the plazas the U where people
would gather to go to the different
events and here is a structural soil uh
done in Sydney and being it's very dry
there they do uh irrigate these trees
but they grow very very
well and even in uh with palm trees here
is the Miami South Beach where Palms
were planted into structural soil and uh
are doing quite well as as long as the
roots can grow far away from the trunk
they have great stability and the these
trees uh withstood several
hurricanes this is New York City a plaza
right near City Hall which is uh honey
locust gleditsia trian planted in
structural soil in the entire area and
these trees are doing very
well we wanted to look more about how we
could create a safe path for roots to
grow in a narrow Tree loone on your left
through to somebody's uh front lawn or
whatever green space on your right
without heing the sidewalks and this is
a Accolade Elm almost U almost Accolade
uhu and we actually taken up two squares
of the sidewalk and dug down UH 60 cm
put structural soil re compacted and
then repaved and after a couple of years
we wanted to look at where the roots
were
growing and so we used ground
penetrating radar to measure uh
nondestructively where the roots were
had the depth and the number of
roots and here's the ground penetrating
radar moving from the um uh normal
sidewalk through the structural Sol so
panel and then to the nor normal
sidewalk again and you can see the
uh Elm trees after about three
years so if you look in plan view on the
right hand side you see the gray squares
that's the uh uncovered Concrete where
we put structural soil and the left
which say number six is just a control
where we planted uh Accolade Elms but
did not change the sidewalk
configuration and on the right you can
see those
pink numbers pink lines which are the
passes of the ground penetrating radar
over that area so over the sidewalk and
then into somebody's front
long so just just explain this to you
the top graph and you can see these X's
the X's are represent
Roots uh both the shallow medium and
deep roots and on your uh left hand axis
you have the depth going down to 28 in
and on the right is your length in feet
as the ground Penny training radar uh
device is moving across the site so from
areas where there's no structural soil
to uh the two middle areas where there's
structural soil and out again where
there's no structural soil the tree is
in the middle about 10 feet from either
end and you can see the roots and the
structural soil panels where that
there's some shallow roots at about 6
Ines and quite a few medium Roots at
about uh 8 to 16 inches and then quite a
few Deep Roots down to about 24 28
inches and a lot of more Roots than in
there than in the Sur the um surrounding
areas where there's no structural soil
the control on the bottom shows you root
growth uh in the same area where the
tree was uh but very very shallow very
few Deep Roots and very few Roots all
together
uh this is another example of using
structural soil where uh the you see the
uh Power Plant there wanted to have a
Access Road into this area this is a
residential neighborhood and there was
two tremendous corcus fellows there
which they did not want to disturb
because it was a residential
neighborhood they wanted to screen the
power plant so they thought about using
retrofitting to use struct ual soil and
as not to disturb these
trees so here with the air excavation
tool again they uncovered roots without
instead of just taking a back ho and
digging them out um uncovering the roots
without disturbing those roots and
without damaging The Roots so here you
see the roots and people don't know
where roots are very often they're right
at the surface so here they are at the
surface as they've been uncovered with
that air excavation
tool so structural soil was then brought
in and uh laid on top of those roots and
compacted in and around those
roots and then
a Paving surface was put right on top of
those the trees on either side never
lost the beat they never stopped growing
they never showed any damage so this is
a way of retrofitting structural soil
where you need to come in and build a
road or have other kind of construction
uction
Activity one thing we've been working on
quite a bit is uh the development and
issues of storm water which is becom a
big part of part of climate change lot
more storm water events and we thought
the part of that problem with that is is
the increased amount of uh impervious
surfaces which are not allowing water to
get into ground so we thought of using
structural soil as part of the solution
for this here's just a flooding event in
Upstate New York on a
highway so structural soil combined with
porous asphalt this would allow water to
filter through pavement slowly
recharging groundwater and reducing the
need for retention or detention ponds
and bioses and it would also allow trees
to grow in pave sites which would also
increase the
uh ecosystem benefits of trees and allow
trees to take up that
water so we could do this we trusted uh
compaction of structural soil we want to
see the macro pores how much water
holding pores there would be with see
your structural soil you'll see that at
95 to 100% Proctor density you only have
26% pore space and soil alone you have
34% pore space but the macro pores the
large pores are much greater in
structure soil 31% in structural soil
versus 2% in soil alone so although you
have more pore space it's very tiny
pores in soil alone where you have a
good percentage of large pores in C
structural soil both of these compacted
to 95% protic density so the
infiltration rate was greater than 24
inches per hour in structural soil
versus a half an inch per hour in soil
alone both being
compacted so because we knew this we
thought this is a trail head uh in itha
New York where the city wanted to build
a parking lot uh instead of this uh
pulloff space and to test structural
soil with porous and nonporous
asphalt so we dug down 24 in in that
site and put structural soil and
compacted it in layers so you n when
you're putting it in you compact it in
layers so that the compaction effort is
as
uh uniform is
necessary and then we put traditional
asphalt on one part and the porous
asphalt on another part you can see in a
rainstorm what the porous asphalt is H
letting water in where the traditional
asphalt is is
not unless if you're not familiar porest
asphalt on the right looks sort of like
uh uh sticky corn uh with pores and the
one that traditional one on the left has
no pore space at
all so after it was laid we saw cut into
the asphalt and planted uh Accolade Elms
as it were again in this spot this was
2005 uh fall of 2005 we used bar root
trees not necessary to use be root but
we did and uh that was 2006 the bottom
right first growing season
we use quite big uh protection on these
trees because of snow plows that come in
here and potentially damage the
trees this was uh about three years
later Tre is doing very well both porous
and non-porous asphalt uh
initially this is
2012 uh trees growing very well well
when we started to see well here's
2016 we started to see uh some
differences just visually on the porous
side the trees looked Fuller they looked
they were growing stronger on the
nonporous side again all of this is
structural soil underneath but they had
porous or non-porous asphalt on the
nonporous side you started to see so
muchat smaller tree growth and uh we
wanted to test
this so again my colleague uh with
ground penetrating radar unit come and
look at where the roots were how deep
they were and how many there were on
both the porous and
nonporous uh structural soil in this
parking
lot so uh these panels as you can see uh
represent passes with the ground
penetrating radar machine and they go
from basically five 5 Ines see the um y
AIS the left hand axis about five or six
inches down to 35 inches deep as the
machine can measure and along the side
about 35 feet in between 15 and 20 or
around 20 feet is where the trees are
planted so what we're seeing with these
passes is that red dots represent roots
and the depth of roots and the number of
roots between on either side of the
trees as they're growing in a nonporous
asphalt so you see tree roots growing
from oh you know eight or so inches down
to about uh 30 Ines and that's the
number of roots you can
see and this is another way of looking
at it from a plan point of view here the
trees in a nonporous asold the hotter
the colors the red or orange colors the
more Roots the blue and green colors the
fewer Roots just another way of looking
at that same
data and here is the root growth of the
trees in Porous
asphalt right away you can see there are
many more Roots here and they go to the
full denth uh depth of about 35 inches
many more Roots at each of the passes of
the ground penetrating radar machine so
this was quite a distinctive difference
and again the plan view of the density
of roots again many more hot brown
orange colors representing more Roots uh
to about that 32 inch
depth so looking at it together the U
gray bars represent
um tree roots in uh root density in
Porous pavement the black is root
density in nonporous pavement at eight
to 0 to8 inches you get quite a bit more
roots surficial in the middle area not
too much difference and greater than 16
in you get only U roots in the porous
pavement so totally you get almost
uh 60% more roots in uh por under porous
pavement than you do under non-porous
pavement we also want to look at tree
growth uh so this is in over 2012 to
2018 uh Chute growth was basically
nonporous with the black and porous with
gray bars so you had uh terminal growth
of these trees basically the same in
2012 in 2013 we started to see a
difference between those and as time
went on we had fewer and fewer or
shorter and shorter root shoot growth
under nonporous asphalt than we did in
Porous asphalt which stayed equally good
for those
years the one thing that we need to
remember about this you can this is a
place in New York City where there's
structural soil underneath but there's
no way for water to get in other than
this uh 18inch by 18inch opening so it's
important to know how to get water into
the soil medium whether it's structural
soil or any other soil and if it's
totally paved with no way of water
getting in or very little way of water
getting in the trees won't do very well
so take home messages SE structural soil
is a viable growing medium that supports
tree growth under Pavements breakout
zones retrofitting and reducing
construction damage combined with porous
pavement structural soil provides a
reservoir for storm water capture under
pavement and a medium for tree
growth but important issues for
successful use of structural soil good
plant selection stral soil is has a
fairly low water holding capacity about
8 to
10% um and that's more typical of trees
in droughty areas water use is important
whether you're going to get the water
into that area by porest pavement or an
opening larger opening where the tree is
growing or use of irrigation all those
things in the western part of the United
States uh irrigation is used um almost
all the time pH the stone is important
we use we have our in Western New York
our pH is our stone is high that's okay
as long as you choose trees that are
tolerant of that high pH whereas in
eastern United States uh the stone is
granite which is neutral so pH is not
such an an issue you need to have a
volume adequate for reduced available
water holding capacity depth no less
than 60 cm or 24 in we prefer more like
90 uh centimeters an adequate pavement
opening for water to entry that's
important wherever your trees are um
being planted and good standard initial
Tree Care these trees are going in they
have probably two or three years before
they really get established and that
would be the same for any tree so those
are caveats to think about plant
selection water use pH adequate volume
and volume opening for getting the tree
water in
so I just leave you uh with thanks this
is my website there's lots more
information on CU structural soil bolon
videos all kinds of things they're
available to u under the Outreach
section you'll see lots of information
on structural soil and I thank you for
your attention and I hope this has been
useful
thanks this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu